Hello everyone. Welcome to a new episode of The
Dissenter. I'm your host, as always, Ricardo Lops, and
today I'm joined by Samantha White. She's a psychotherapist
and the founder of Taboo Education, an independent business
based in Perth, Western Australia, dedicated to improving how
medical professionals approach death, dying and end of life
care. She also has a YouTube channel with the
same name, Taboo Education, Let's Talk Deaf, and today
we're going to talk about deaf and and deaf
literacy. So Samantha, welcome to the show. It's a
big pleasure to everyone. I really love your channel,
so it's uh great to have you here.
Hi Ricardo, lovely to be here.
OK, great. So uh let me start with more
of a personal question, I guess. What got you
interested in topics related to death?
Uh, WELL, I've always been interested in what society
deems as taboo and, and not to talk about
and, and things like that. Um, I guess as
a kid I wasn't allowed to ask anything about
death. That was something that our family would, you
know, never talk about that, that sort of stuff.
Um, AND as I got older, I went into
a different career, and then, you know, I started
helping out with my aging grandmother who was obviously
getting on in age and needed help, and I
started seeing how frightened everyone around seemed to be
about death, whether it be, you know, in the
nursing staff. That were around families of other patients
that were around, and that kind of annoyed me
in a lot of ways, um, not their, not
their feelings about it so much, but the fact
that we should know this, and we did up
to a, you know, up to a few decades
ago, we were OK with it. Um, SO that's
probably where that came from, it's more, I like
to make other people feel uncomfortable while trying to
get them back to comfort on a very, on
various topics, so. That's sort of where that started
out and then COVID came around and it was
the perfect time to make a change while everyone
was still thinking about it and it was very
fresh in everyone's head.
Yeah, I, I mean, I guess that's uh the
bit about being interested in taboo topics. I share
that with you because I've also explored all kinds
of taboo topics on the show. I mean, of
course, also many mainstream topics, but taboo topics is
not uncommon here. So, um, what, what would you
say deaf literacy is about? What does it encompass
really?
Well, when you look up the definition as far
as uh what most, uh organizations would put out
there, it's about the education and the understanding of
end of life options and what happens when dying
and putting in sort of advanced care directives, these
sorts of things. It's the education about end of
life. I'd say it would go further and for
my company, that's what we do, we do go
further and to educate more about death, anxiety and
existential dread. Which is something that human beings have
and you either work through it or you don't,
so, and it's the education of understanding around how
that affects your day to day life, and for
some people it really impacts them, it impacts the
decisions that they, that they make and the conversations
they have, um, so I'd say death literacy is
really learning about, What death is, what it means
socially, physiologically, medically, all that sort of, all the
stuff to understand and become more accepting of that
as a topic because human beings die, that's what
we're built to do. If you're alive, you're gonna
die, that's how it works. Um, SO to become
accepting of, of that is probably what death literacy
is about and knowing options and knowing how to
understand it.
Yeah, and I guess we're going to get, as
we go through the topics here, we're going to
get into uh why uh the different ways that
death, anxiety and people not really knowing enough about
death can affect their lives and the kinds of
bad decisions that they can make because of that.
But uh let me, let me start by asking
you about uh. Deaf anxiety. I mean, what is
deaf anxiety really and where does it stem from?
I mean, is it really just something that we
are naturally predisposed towards or, uh, do you think
that it is in a way reinforced by the
kinds of uh death avoiding cultures that we live
in?
Yeah, I'd say it's both, it's, it's a natural
part of being a human being because us like
unlike other animals and and other living things, we
know we have an expiry date, and that's hard
for us to really reconcile with or for a
lot of people. The difference being nowadays, and when
you said about different cultures and different time periods,
is that, we have changed a lot because we
don't see it as much anymore. If you look
at someone in a war-torn country that's seen death
day after day, they would naturally have less, They
will be more accepting of death as a concept
rather than what we are over here, because it's
sort of that hidden monster. You just, you just
never see it. Um, I'm not sure what it
was like over you, over Portugal way, but over
here, um, our big cultural shift happened around the,
um, the World Wars, right? They suddenly graves weren't
being dug by families. Suddenly the wake wasn't happening
at home. Hospitals started taking over, you know, medical,
um, uh, challenges started to be taken over because,
you know, they knew how to work with it
now, thanks to the war, you know, war advances
bring medical advances and. Um, AS they said in
MAS and, um, so, and then the funeral home
came along and they started taking care of that
option as well. So most people have never seen
a dead body and therefore, all these sort of
myths come around in their mind, they start to,
to, it gets out of control, that fear gets
out of control. Um, SO that's what death anxiety
is, it stems from something that is evolutional. It
stems from something that is very real because we
know about our own death, but it's much harder
for us to sort of control if you never
see it at all and your mind decides to
fill in the blanks for you.
And please correct me if I'm wrong, but I
think that it's about people not seeing dead bodies
and also people not being exposed to the dying
process, right? I mean, they don't see people while
they're in the process of. Dying really unless they
are, I don't know, nurses, doctors, people working at
hospices and places like that, right?
Yes, absolutely. People used to die at home surrounded
by friends and families. Now they're surrounded by Machines
and, you know, you see people that are coming
into a hospice, families coming into hospice, and they,
and they panic when they see someone who is
actively in the active stages of dying because it
doesn't look like what it looked like on TV
where it looks so peaceful, you know, they just
close their eyes and oh, I'm dead now. It's,
it can look horrific, um, if you don't know
what you're looking for, for hospice staff, they're looking
at it going, well, this is what we see
every day. For someone else, it's, it's not what
it's like on the movies, it's not what it's
like on TV, but it is natural, um, and
that's very confronting for a lot of people, so
not knowing that, Um, not knowing what that looks
like, ah, it, you know, that can be the
start of a nightmare if you, if you don't
actually know what it's like, but, um, it is
very real, and that, yeah, that, that sense really
brings on the anxiety as, as well, if you
don't know what to expect.
Uh, BUT since you are a psychotherapist, uh, I'm
curious. Uh, OF course, I'm not sure if you
have an answer to this or not, but, uh,
do we know at all if there are people
with certain, uh, psychological traits, personality traits, for example,
who are more predisposed to suffering from deaf anxiety
than others or not?
Not so much personality types, there are certain personality
types that are less likely to, to deal with
it. Someone with antisocial personality disorder, for instance, is
less likely to have that anxiety, um, but it
can be an underlying factor for a lot of
mental health challenges, for instance, I know depression, OCD,
anxiety, uh, a wide range of, Of diagnosis and
and and illnesses have death anxiety underneath, but because,
so many clinicians don't know what um death anxiety
is and what to look for, They don't really
get to the root of the issue and therefore
can't really help someone move forward, um, but yeah,
OCD panic, anyone that deals with panic as well,
it's a huge, it's a huge problem for them
and they're more likely to have it, but it's
more so that's, it's more so that is the
underlying issue that then comes out as depression or
panic and, and things like that.
Mhm. So, in our cultures like yours in Australia,
mine in Portugal, because when it comes to death,
you can believe that it's uh it's pretty much
the same. I mean, we, people here don't like
dealing or seeing death happening, dead people, all of
that, I mean it's. It's the same. So, what,
uh, because we live in cultures like that, what
would you say are perhaps the most common misconceptions
people have about death and dying? I mean, in
your process of educating people about these topics, uh,
what are the most common misconceptions you've come across?
Um, THAT death is instant. There's, there's that, you're
either alive or dead. There's actually a process. There
are stages that, that you go through to, for
stages of dying that you go through. What that
looks like, um, a lot of people don't know
about, you know, how the funeral industry works, about
advanced care directives, how to write them, what to
look for. Um, JUST the whole, whole range of
things, it comes down to even basic things, insurance,
like travel insurance. People don't know what to look
for for repatriation, um, and they don't even think
to, to do that, but that, you know, and
that impacts a, a whole, whole range of things.
Uh, AND I've completely forgotten the question, I'm sorry.
Uh, NO, I mean the question was about, uh,
what do you think are the most common misconceptions
people have about death and dying because they're not
exposed, uh, to it.
Pretty much anything that, that people, a lot of
people think dead bodies are, are dangerous, just inherently
dangerous. You stop breathing, your heart stops, and suddenly
your body's dangerous. It's, it's absolutely not true, unless
you've died of Ebola. Um, IT'S really unlikely that,
that the body is going to be a problem.
If you leave the body out, you know, if
you're in a, a war zone or something, you
leave the body out and decompose, then it starts
to become a public health issue. So there's that
problem, there's the, Yeah, the, the stages of dying,
just not knowing what to, what to look for,
what to say, how to talk to people uh
about it.
Yeah, but do you think, even though of course
it's natural for us to have a predisposition toward,
uh, death, anxiety and fearing death, um, do you
think that there's a, a in a more rational,
from a more rational perspective, that people should fear
death? I mean, do, do you think that there's
good reason for people to fear death?
Uh, WELL, it's not really for me to say,
is it? It's. Should people fear death? I would
say no, I think it's, it's a natural thing
that happens. I think our society is put on
many conditions that would say that you need to
fear it, um, and I mean this could be,
there's so many problems with various worldviews that say
that you should, um, That it is the worst
thing, but I've seen plenty of people that are
living with conditions, plenty of people who are injured,
plenty of people with things that their quality of
life is none, and death would be, uh, a
better outcome for them, and yet their family keeps
trying to bring them back, you know, CPR on
a 90 year old who's already got cracked ribs,
that's, you know, that's puncturing inside things, but keeping
them alive is, is, is better than that. Um,
SO, I mean if you've got, but also religion
comes into play and religion is a, is a,
You know, people, it's a very controversial topic for
a lot of people, but it was built out
of death anxiety, a way to explain what happens.
And if, and it's been proven, there's a lot
of studies out there that deeply, deeply religious people
of any faith, that particularly one that has an
afterlife, often die worse because they keep trying to
keep them alive so much, and they are scared
about, Dying and then having, um, a god or
something, make a decision on where you go. Did
you do good enough? So naturally they're scared to
die because they're scared for the next outcome. Um,
SO it's, it's, it's a whole, there's a lot
of societal things that would make death scary, but
then also people don't know what's next, you know,
it depends on what you believe. If, if you
believe there is nothing, Then, and you're rotting in
the ground or whatever, well that's one thing, but
if you think there's something else, well then you
may be scared of it. I think most people
are more scared of the actual dying than the
death. I think that's, that seems to be what
I've found. More people are scared of the, the
act of dying or being in pain, of the
lack of dignity, or that sort of thing seems
to be what scares people the most.
But do you think that people are also scared
of the idea of just not being there? I
mean, the idea of nothingness, non-continuity, things like that,
do you think that those kinds of things also
scare people? Sure,
the. F can be huge for a lot of
people, that the, you know, the fact that you
don't, you're not there anymore, will people forget that
you ever existed is huge for a lot of
people, that's why a lot of people do sort
of immortality projects and legacy building and stuff beforehand
so their memory lives on. For them. Um, BUT
also, I think people also went, think, well, what
will happen to my family and, and stuff like
that. So they're fearing death because of what will
happen for other people, but that, that not knowing
what, what comes next and being forgotten is huge
for a lot of people. It's huge for certain
personality types more than others, um, but yeah, that,
that can be a huge, huge part of it.
So, uh, since you mentioned religion a minute ago,
uh, does the way that, er, religious beliefs manifest,
er, have anything to do with, uh, terror management
theory, or not?
Yeah, that one would say, you know, terror management
theory, uh, came from Ernest Becker and then got
sort of evolved by, by more people. Um, AS
a sort of method of escapism and through cultural
beliefs, to try and manage the, the existential dread,
the, the knowing that, that you will die and
what people put in place and their worldviews that
get put into place in order to make them
feel like they matter. Um, SO yeah, religion is
a big part and it's a, it's, it's a
huge part of trying to get people to understand
why, what meaning of life, effectively, you know, the
meaning of life is to do good in this
one, to get onto the, the next, um, and
it's that a fear of dying, that fear of
nothing, that maybe after that, they didn't like that
idea, so they put something else in, in place,
rather than accepting that nothing is OK. Um, NOW
if that helps people, then that's, if that generally
helps people as individuals, then that's fine, it's when
it goes on to interfere with everyone else's beliefs
that it, it, it becomes more of an issue
and it starts to impart their death anxiety onto
everyone else as well, um, not just the religious
beliefs themselves.
Yes, and I think that we'll probably come back
to this when we talk about things like medical
assistance in dying, but I would imagine that some
of those beliefs then people also try to impose
even politically on others, right? They try to impose
on others how they should deal with their own
death or their process of dying,
correct? Oh yeah. Oh absolutely, there's a lot of
that going on at the moment.
Yeah, but I, I mean, uh, because I was
asking you if people should really fear death. I
mean, what do we know about how er the
process of dying usually plays out? I mean, are
most deaths peaceful or not?
Depends how you define peaceful. For the, if you're
dying, say in hospice, you're dying after a long
illness and you have pain medications and, and all
that stuff, it can't be peaceful for the individual
who is actually dying. It may not look peaceful
for the family members around them, um, often they,
they would describe it as anything but that, but
for the, for the actual individual it seems to
be OK. There's often this thought of, um, you
know, dying peacefully in your sleep at night, you
know, that's how I'd, I'd like to go. It's
unlikely that that peacefulness that an ambulance crew would
see next thing in the morning is actually how
it happened, um, but there's a big difference between
having a heart attack or an aneurysm or something
like that, the, what happens to the body when
it happens, so peaceful, If you're dying naturally, is
debatable. um, THERE are certain more peaceful ways than
others, but then you have something like voluntary assisted
suicide, which by all accounts, even family members that
are around, would say that was looked peaceful to
them.
Right, but uh I, I mean, I'm not sure
if, er, of course not everyone dies this way.
I mean there are sudden deaths, for example, but
er what people in hospice care, doctors, nurses call
uh active dying, I mean that process when people
get into it, uh, do they suffer usually or
not? I mean, even sometimes those images. Videos that
we can uh see on the internet specifically where
people do those weird uh noises with their uh
lungs. I mean that, that seems like they are
grasping for air, but it's really not that, uh,
I mean, is that, uh, is that, uh, difficult
at all or, uh, do people experience suffering at
all when they are going through that?
Uh, YEAH, so that would be the death rattle
that people talk about. I was missing, um, so
that's the, that's the term that they give. The,
the stages of dying, there's 5 stages of dying,
and the first few stages, it's usually around 72
hours that the 5 stages will take roughly speaking,
um, and the first few, yeah, People, you know,
their bodies can contort, which can be incredibly creepy
to, to see, but also, you know, they're getting
very, they often get very irritated if they've got
sort of linen, something wrapped around them. Think of
it like going back to infancy, where an infant
will cry because they've got something wrapped around them
that they, but they don't know what it is,
they can't tell you, so your job as a
family member is to, Is to work out what's
wrong, it may be the light, it may be
some, you know, something completely innocuous. Um, SO for
those individuals, for that first part, yeah, there can
be a lot of pain, that's why you go
into hospice to manage that, but say you were
dying at home in the same thing without those
pain meds, the pain meds, the nausea meds, the
anti-constipation, they are the three most common used meds,
um, in hospice, and they are absolutely needed because
those are the three things that, Um, caused the
most, um, uncomfortable feelings for the person. One can't
say whether it's, it's gonna be painful or not.
We do know that if you are in the
last stages of cancer, for instance, which is one
of the most common, uh, conditions that we, people
around the world will now die of, yeah, it's
gonna be painful. That's why you've got the pain
meds in there. Um, YOU know, people often talk
about, you know, the good death back in the
1800s when it was called, and it wasn't. You
know, it might be good as far as you
weren't covered by machines, you had family around you,
but these people were in a lot of pain
back then. They were sick, they were nauseous, they,
and there was nothing that could be done apart
from pray, which, let's be honest, didn't really do
all that much. So peaceful death and, and are
they in pain? Absolutely. And that's why nowadays with
modern medicine, we can help them through that. But
sometimes, depending on what it is, particularly if someone,
someone's got 80% burns or something like that, no
amount of pain meds is going to, is going
to take away everything from that. So, um, it
really depends on the, on the condition. But the
actual, the last stages of dying is, is pretty
peaceful. I mean, it sounds, you've got fluid in
the back of your lungs and, and so you're
making gargling noise, but, It's for, by all accounts,
you know, cos we're monitoring heart rates, if you're
in hospice, you're monitoring heart rates, you're monitoring blood
pressure, so you can see they're not stressed, um,
it just happens that it doesn't really sound very
pleasant when you're the family member, uh, sitting by
their bedside.
So, uh, at those later stages, people are no
longer conscious, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah. The vast, the vast majority of
the time they are, yep, they're out, they're unconscious,
it's just the body doing the last bits of
work to wind down, because that whole act of
dying period, the, the five stages is simply your
body winding down. It's certainly, sort of like going
through an office building and turning off the lights
as you go out for the night, you know,
you're slowly winding down. So by the end of,
by the end of it, those last things, it
is pretty peaceful for the vast majority of people.
Right. So what does end of life care encompass?
I mean, when you talk about end of life
care, what kinds of things are you referring to
exactly and uh why do you think that it
is important to address that topic uh when talking
about deaf literacy?
Um, IT'S important because a lot of people don't
know it exists and don't know what it means.
Um, A lot of people think hospice care and
palliative care are the same thing. They're not. Palliative
care is used a lot in hospice care. But
just because you're being given palliative care for something
else doesn't necessarily mean you're dying. Um, IT can,
palliative care can be used in, it's often used
in burn units, it's used in cancer units, uh,
all that sort of stuff as well, even when
you're not dying. So end of life care is,
uh, your medical care, your spiritual care, your social,
so and all, all, everything like that, and if
for hospice care mainly, Um, it's, it's about all
those things. It's about giving you the quality of
the best quality of life that you can, for
the, for the time that you have left. It's
taking away the treatment part of it. So we're
still giving you the meds to support you. We're
still giving you the um sort of the pain
meds and the anti-nausea, but we're taking away the
treatment. We've, we've decided treatment is enough, and we're
gonna stop that because a lot of treatment is,
is very debilitating, can make you very, very sick.
Um, SO we take it off that and then
you live the next few months. Yes, you will
die within those 3 months, but you will likely
feel a lot better without, The treatment, so that's
end of life, end of life care and there's
specific training for that for, for most people, you
can receive it in a facility, you can receive
it at a hospital, you can receive it at
home, um, and there's a lot more options when
it comes to uh hospice care.
When it comes to end of life, does it
complicate things if the person who's dying is doing
everything to try to deny it? I mean that
they're just in denial. Oh, I'm not going to
die, I'm not going to die, I'm going to
get. Better, whatever, I mean things like that, does
that complicate the process?
Oh, absolutely, um, you would rarely get someone that's
in death denial, to go to hospice, um, because
if you don't believe you're dying, you're not going
to say yes to somewhere where you go to
die, obviously, um, Yes, people in death denial are
usually very independent types of people, usually very stubborn
types of people. Um, WE commonly see it a
lot in farmers over here. I'm sure you probably
do over, over, over your way as well. Um,
THAT kind of personality type, that strong independent personality
type is usually going to deny it all the.
Way up to the end, and I've seen people
who deny it all the way up to the
end, and it's, it's incredible. It's hard to really
wrap your mind around that someone can feel everything
going on in their body. They, they feel them
going downhill, and they, and they can't accept it
or even acknowledge it. I mean, we're, we're not
necessarily asking for acceptance that they're dying, but, You
know, asking for them to acknowledge that it's, it's
happening, and the pro the big, the big, big
problem is when you have, the patient that is
actively dying, or, you know, has 6 months to
live, and, They don't believe it, and they refuse
to believe it, no matter how many facts you
give, and you can't have those conversations with their
family, as well, the family may have acknowledged it,
but they can't then have those closure conversations with
the dying person, they can't have the conversations about
what do you want, you know, as far as
advanced care planning, they can't have the conversations about
the will. There's, there's so, So much things, it
hurts the family much more than the dying individual
because the dying individual will be dead. By the
end of this, it does hurt them as far
as the treatment or as far as what care
they receive, because if they still want to actively
undergo treatment, they're obviously gonna be in a lot
more pain, a lot more discomfort than what they
were if they were on palliative care, so it
hurts them then, but it's the long-term, Uh, issues
that it causes their family, that's probably it that's
the most ongoing thing, and that's the hardest thing
to deal with, because, you know, they're looking at
if, you know, I'm, I'm the psych, right, and
they're telling us, you know, get dad to understand
so I can have these conversations, um, and, and
you can't, and if someone is in that much
of denial, eventually you just have to go, This
is, this is where we're at, we have to
accept that. You can write letters to your dad,
in this case, um, and leave them with, with
him and maybe he will read them. Um, AND
so, and then it becomes a different sort of
grief, it really complicates the family's grief and ability
to go through that, and then the practicalities around
it, it, yeah, it can be a very, very
long, uh, period of grief after that.
Uh, ALSO, I think related to what you said,
and this is of course extremely unfortunate, but there
are some people, uh, that, uh, also because of
their personality type, I mean they tend to be
a little bit more manipulative and things like that
and because they are in depth. They also put
their own family members through much more complications than
they could have been put through because I mean
they they sort of force their family members if
they need to take care of them even though.
Death for them is inevitable and if they don't
do that or if they're really tired of doing
it, then they blame them, oh, it's your fault
that I'm like this, you don't want to take
care of me, things like that, so that, that
kind of thing can also happen.
Right. Yeah, I mean, caregiving is such, such hard
work and, You know, people, a lot of people
that have never done any caregiving, have a lot
of opinions about caregivers. Oh, they have a lot
of opinions, oh, you should do that. Um, UNTIL
you've actually done at least a solid month 24/7
of caregiving, um, I don't think your opinion is,
uh, should really come into the conversation. Um, BUT
yes, if you've got, say, a, a family member,
we'll say a parent in this situation, particularly someone
who comes with, say, narcissistic personality disorder, it can
be a huge, uh, issue, uh, within the family,
because obviously you don't want to take care of
that person because they're abusing you. So, um, there,
there's massive complications, family dynamics are a huge issue.
And nowadays because a lot of us lived in
individualistic societies, whereas they weren't as much back in
the day, um, a lot of people just opt
out, and one person is left dealing with, the,
the dying individual, even whether they are a lovely
person or not. Uh, ONE person, and it's, it's
usually the daughter that gets, that gets stuck with
it, and everyone else goes, and then they only
turn up, you know, the week before someone dies
and then demand that they be kept alive, no
matter what, no matter that the daughter and the
parent had actually discussed this sort of thing. Um,
YEAH, there's a lot of, you could say that
that's guilt, uh, I, Every time I've seen it,
I, I don't believe that for a second. Um,
I'd say it's more about, it's about control. There's
a lot of control, um, family dynamics out there.
Um, IT'S what, they don't want to be seen
as the bad person that did nothing to help
the carer, and the, and the conversation always comes
out, particularly in, you know, we've seen it on
social media at the moment, oh well, my parents
shouldn't demand that I care for them and, and
stuff like that. So there's, there's, there's a lot
of, er, there's a lot of nuance in, in
family dynamics, um, but the fact that it's always
seems to get put on one child, and it's
usually the daughter, um, is, is a big problem
within many, many communities, um, that's not really understood
and leads to a lot of family dynamics, particularly
when the will comes out. Uh, AFTERWARDS that the,
the other kids find out they're not in it,
shockingly, um, yeah, things, things like this are, uh,
you know, that part of death anxiety doesn't get
talked about, uh, as much, no one wants to
talk about you won't get the money, you won't
get the inheritance if you don't help out, that's,
you know, that's not seen as socially acceptable to
talk about, but, uh, you know.
Yeah, uh yeah, and I think it's very unfortunate
because I mean, people could be helping a little
bit in at least alleviating some of those family
dynamics, but because even society at large, if they
expect. PATIENTS are put on a particular person to
take care of their dying relative and then suddenly
the person is already so stressed, so tired, so
overwhelmed that they do not do. Enough, uh, uh,
according to other people's perspectives, then they're put even
through, uh, more, uh, stigma and, and things like
that, right, because, oh, now you're the bad person
here because you, you no longer want to. Do
your duty and take care of your dying mother,
father, brother, whoever. Oh yeah,
it happens so much and you know, if you
choose to put your, your family member in an
aged care facility or any other sort of facility,
The backlash that you often get from family, the
backlash you get from your community can be huge,
but it's the same as in the disability community.
If you've got a severely disabled child that you
can no longer care for or they've gotten too
big and you can't care for them, and then
you put them in a, in a facility, um,
very similar, uh, outcomes there from the community who
will describe you as the most evil person imaginable.
Uh, AND again it goes back to, if you
have not done a day of caring in your
life, um, I don't really feel your opinion's all
that valid, and, um, that's probably a controversial thing
to say, but it's, it's the truth, it is
extremely hard and we, I mean we've had cases
over here, um, of murder suicides. Because of that,
because there is no support from anyone else, and
yet then they get seen as the bad person
when they were doing what they felt was, Their
only option, um, I don't think people have the,
have the right to really criticize and have an
opinion and call them evil when they did nothing
to step up and help themselves.
Yeah, and I mean the person who's the caregiver
is going through many, many things at the same
time. I mean they, they're losing their family member,
they're feeling isolated because no one steps in to
help, at least with some of uh with some
of the load they're er they're getting. Ostracized by
other people if other people think they're not doing
enough, they are absolutely stressed, perhaps sleep deprived, tired,
I mean it's sometimes it's really nasty,
right? Absolutely, the burnout and the compassion fatigue that
you see in carers is extreme and there is
no, there's no respite, there's, there's often nothing. And
that and financially, um, it, it costs so, so,
so much, caring costs so much, the ability, you
know, all the, the equipment and the, the medical,
uh, all the items that you, that you need,
you're no longer working, so there's no income coming
in, if that's a family that you've got coming
in, so it goes on to another family member,
which is probably, say their partner. Who then has
to look after the family, so that creates relationship
stress, then the, if you've got kids, then they're
thinking, well, where's mum? Why isn't she here? I
mean, I, I vividly remember this throughout my childhood
when my mum was caring for my grandmother, and
so we've got two, it was me and my
brother going, Where's mum, I remember the arguments that
mum and dad would have because she wasn't around,
um, you know, and then that came back when
it switched around and dad had to care for
his parents, but it's, yeah, it's a huge, it's
a huge thing. And because people nowadays don't live
in the same homes, you know, you see other
countries, a lot of Asian countries, for instance, have,
uh, multi-generational family homes and, and dwellings. So it,
it's sort of, you know, that comes with its
own pros and cons for this situation as well.
Yeah. So, uh, let me ask you now about,
uh, how death tends to be approached by medical
professionals because unfortunately, this might also have some negative
ramifications in terms of how end of life. Care
is done and all of that and perhaps trying
to overextend people's lives. So how do you look
at how uh medical professionals tend to deal with
uh death and death as a A result of
whatever they're doing to a patient.
Yeah, there's a lot of studies, a lot of
research that have gone into this, and it's the
fact that the medical industry really advanced very quickly
over a number of decades, and when you see
what a medical professional, let's say a doctor in
this specific instance, The, the training that they go
through, it is all cure, cure, cure. It's all
how to keep the patient alive, it's all, that's,
that's your job, you know, a, a kid says,
what does a doctor do, you know, you save
people. So that's their mentality and certain, certain um
specialities, uh, in medicine do better with their anxiety
than others, uh, surgeons are seen to be some
of the um, Have it the worst, you, you
could say, and you know, no one must die,
when it comes to me, and if someone does,
they, you know, the whole identity is, is cracked,
whereas other say emergency departments, not so much. Um,
THE problem with, with doctors that can't accept death
as an outcome, Um, is that the treatment options
can be brutal and the manipulation that it takes
can be brutal. Now we're not saying a surgeon
that leaves a, leaves a clamp in a patient
and then they die, of course that is a
failure, um, that, that led to death, but, if
you're a doctor that doesn't want your patient to
die because you're worried about your professional reputation, or
you can't handle it within yourself, a death yourselves,
there, I wouldn't say they, they actively manipulate a
patient, but a lot of them can sort of
passively manipulate, they, they sort of really push, oh
you know, you should really try this 10 there's
not too many um bad outcomes for this, or
have, have you tried this particular outcome, and even
when a, a patient will say, I've had enough,
I'm, I'm, I'm done, they will go, oh, well
for your family you should try this, and, It
leads to patients having treatments that have very little
benefit, but have huge uh implications for them, um,
and, you know, patients might not actually live longer
than what they would have if they hadn't gone
through treatment, but they lived that time in, in
horrific pain and things like that. But then you've
also got doctors say, You know, uh, CPR is
one of the big ones, and a lot of
people don't really understand what, what CPR looks like,
and doctors will continue to perform it or be
told to perform it. um, AND if you've got
a fragile, particularly in the elderly or anyone with
a fragile, uh, skeleton, that cracks ribs. You have
to crack ribs to do CPR properly. You've gotta
get to the heart, and how do you get
through that? You've gotta get through the, you know,
the ribs are there to protect it, so, um,
Yeah, there's, there's so many treatment options that the
doctors, and often doctors will try to do because
they've been trained year after year, you know, you've
got 1015 years of training, all about keeping someone
alive and treating them and curing them and not.
Not really much training at all. Um, SOME doctors
have said, oh, we may have had a unit.
Some have said we may have had a, you
know, a lecture about it over 15 years of
how to help a person die peacefully, um, and
obviously that's, that's not going to be forgotten. There's
a lot of stress and, and professional reputation at
risk. Um, AND in certain countries, um, you know,
certain countries love to sue. Um, AND so that's
the other, that's the other issue that, that, uh,
comes around for patients, doctors wanting to keep their
patients alive no matter what.
Yes, I, I was actually going to ask you
about that. I mean, do you think that this
sort of attitudes that medical professions develop toward death
as an outcome and really trying at all costs
to keep patients alive even if they don't even
have any real quality of life, they're, they're already
extremely debilitated. I mean, do you think that Uh,
it's sort of a combination of our natural tendency
exacerbated by the sort of attitude culturally that we
have toward death combined with the medical technology that
nowadays we have at our disposal where people think,
oh, OK, we, if we have means, technological means
to keep the person alive, then we should do
it or do. Do you think that there's also
an element of the doctor being afraid of how
he or she would be looked at by uh
their colleagues, uh, other people from the broader community,
the family members of the patient, and perhaps even
a, a certain fear of being accused of neglect
or something like that.
Um, YEAH, I think in er different countries, I'd
say different medical communities fear different things in particular.
Um, THERE was a study, it was back in
early 2000s, so it's a bit old now, but
there was a study that said that, uh, US,
uh, doctors fear, um, being sued and, and being
told that they were neglectful of medical neglect and
stuff like that. Um, IN the UK it was
more profession, uh, professional reputation. Um, THERE was a
few others around the place, but so it seems
to be very, uh, country specific in the way
that their training and their, uh, their environment is,
is set up, which I thought was really interesting,
as well, um. Yep.
Yeah, it's, it's complicated, I understand, but I mean.
Yeah. Uh, SO, uh, I mean, what, why is
it, uh, I, I, I, I mean, I know,
I know that it still involves those kinds of
things that we've just talked about, but why is
it that even when the patient, uh, themselves say
or express that they don't really Want to try
anything new that they just want to uh live
life as peacefully as possible and as quickly as
possible because they just can't bear it anymore. Why
is it that even in those sort of situations
medical professionals still try to. Vince or force the
patient into uh extending their life.
Yeah, for a lot of them, death anxiety is
a part of their life as well, you know,
they're still human beings living in our community, they're
brought up in our culture as well, so death
anxiety is, is big for them. And they've been
told they need to cure, they've been told they
need to treat, and they have no idea how
to let someone go peacefully. Um, AND they, they
seem to think that the patient is just giving
up when they have so many other treatment options.
And a lot of doctors, we saw, there was
a, was it the UK? I say UK or
Spain. Somewhere from there. There was a study out
there that, A lot of doctors wanted to use
the treatments that they hadn't been able to use
yet so they could see how it would work.
So they would get patients that had already said,
no, I don't really want to, and they'd go,
oh well there's this, there's this um particular trial
going on, or just, just go see how that
will, that will work. So they're no longer seeing
them as a patient anymore, they're seeing them as
a project. Um, AND that can get, and certain,
certain specialities of medicine do that a lot more
than, than others, um, as seeing a, a patient
as a project and not actually, um, looking at
them directly in the eye and seeing them as
a human being, um, so that that detachment is,
is very real as well.
But do you think that er in the context
of er medical care or healthcare, death should be
considered a failure?
Yeah, look, there's, there's different ways, it was from
neglect, obviously, or mental, you know, of course that's
a failure. No, I mean, no one's saying it's
not, but death is the natural outcome of being
alive. You will die eventually, that's just how this
works. We're not made of Styrofoam, we're not gonna
just continue existing. So how you can say that
someone that's, you know, 90 years old, them dying
is a failure, it's not, they've just come to
the expiry of that life. That's, that was what's
meant to happen, that is what's naturally meant to
happen. Um, SO, Yeah, it's hard for people to,
to sometimes wrap their mind around that. Again, it's
such an abstract concept to a lot of people
because again, they've never seen it and they're scared
of it, and they've made up different things in
their mind, but that is the natural part of
it. And that's what makes, you know, for a
lot of people, it makes life worth living. You
get to do all this, all this stuff, um,
otherwise you would have no goals. You would have
nothing to move forward to if you just lived
forever. Um, AND certainly there's, you know, there's people
that love the idea of cryonics that can say,
oh yeah, we'll, we'll pop back to life in
200 years' time and all will be fine, and
I mean that's death anxiety in a tube right
there, but hey, if you've got the money, go
for it, why not? Um, WHO'S, who's telling you
not, but, uh, yeah, that, that's kind of where
it's at at the moment.
Yeah, and, and I guess that there's also, um,
I mean, or, or there should be a limit
to uh how people should be trying to overextend
their lives, I guess, because I, I mean, I,
I don't think that it's, it will ever even
be biologically possible for anyone to live forever. And
even if at a certain point, I, I have
no idea how people would be able to live
forever. I mean, it also depends on what you
mean by forever, right? Because if the physicists are
right. Even if it's only in I don't know,
11 trillion or a quad trillion years in the
future, there will be a time where the universe
will no longer be able to sustain life. I
mean, so, uh, why should even people uh uh
try to aim at living forever? I mean, that's
just not physically or biologically possible.
I think there's also the arrogance of being a
human being that comes into that, that you have
the right to live forever and take up space
forever. Um, THAT'S part of being a human, that's,
that's a human being thing, you don't see other
animals that doing that as well. Um, PARTLY, yes,
that arrogance, arrogance comes stems from insecurity, which would
stem from their death anxiety as well, but it's
the same thing that we see in, say, a
lot of, Cemeteries, right? Um, SOME, in some countries,
there's, in some countries it's, uh, you're there for
15 years, and for other countries, it is expected
that you will be there forever. It is, you
have expected that you will be able to take
up that space forever, um. And that's, that's an,
an interesting part of the human psyche really that
I, that I find fascinating, is that, and that's
that wanting to be remembered, that's the not wanting
to be forgotten part, that part of the death
anxiety that comes in there, and the reality is
that's not possible. It's just not possible. We do
have, I mean, some people will say that cemetery
shouldn't exist at all. I say that's, that's not
true. I don't think that's a good thing at
all. But you, but the taking up forever of
being in a grave is, is a different thing
entirely.
Yeah, yeah, uh, uh, uh, we're going to come
back to that when later I ask you about
death-related rituals and why they are so important to
people in general, but, um, do you think that,
uh, I, I think I've at least watched one
video where you talked about, uh, um, I mean,
positive, I, I mean, people being uh positively. Or
toxically positive in in a way, so can some
attitudes that people have toward life and death fall
under that rubric of toxic positivity?
Oh yeah, so yeah, toxic positivity being the, um,
you must always look on the, on the positive
side. There's no, there's no room for anything negative
to be said and, and things, and you know,
words like, um, you know, any life is better
than no life. Uh, KIND of thing, or you
know, just look on the bright side, or, oh,
everything happens for a reason, all these sort of
bumper sticker sayings that, that, get, get put out
there, uh, you know, they're in a better place,
it's like well that's great, anywhere but here with
me apparently is a better place you know. Um,
SO toxic positivity, it really impacts, uh, people, like,
even those with disabilities, you know, non-terminal disabilities, it
impacts as well, um, but for the dying, if
you are, if you have a family member that
is, uh, unable to really shift that toxic positivity,
and they are much, you must fight. Of course,
my family member will fight, um, they will be
fine, you know, they've, they've had a heart attack
before, they'll be fine. Um, IT means that there's
no room for an honest conversation about what's happening
next. There's no room for that dying individual to
express what they feel, what they need when they're
just getting these bumper stickers coming back at them,
like you don't, you must always smile, um, and
that sort of thing. And it's, it's not a
good way to go, it's not good for the
person who's going to eventually be grieving, it's not
good for the dying individual. Um, THEMSELVES, and you
see it a lot, toxic positivity comes, you see
a lot in social media when people document their
experiences and going, oh, I'm feeling blessed about my
current situation. I'm feel, it's a miracle that I'm
still alive, all, all these sort of, Really over
the top without looking at the negative, because you
can be, you can be positive about your outlook,
but there has to be room for the negative
feeling and to be able to feel that negative,
uh, feeling as, as well. But also, the toxic
positivity, the big one is the, the medical TV
shows that we see, these sort of outlier moments
where someone has been in a coma for 20
odd years, which we, we did a video about
how that's actually not a great thing, but anyway,
there have been a, 20 odd years and then
suddenly they woke up and they were completely fine
and they went off to work the next week.
It's absolute bullshit, because some of these outliers, um,
they're called outliers for a reason, and the likelihood
of that actually being your loved one that's in
the bed, that's in the coma, that's been there
for, you know, a week, and your doctors are
saying, well, actually they're not in a coma, they
are brain dead, which is a completely different thing.
Um, BUT they still look to these outliers, and
that's part of toxic positivity as well. You know,
it's that keeping up of hope when the facts
in front of you say something completely different and
you refuse to believe them and refuse to say,
well, you know, this, this could happen and, You
leave your, your, your loved one that can't, has
no chance of dying peacefully because you're in charge
of them, which is why I tell everyone to
write an advance care directive and lodge it, please,
if you don't want to be in that situation.
Yeah, and I, I also think, and please correct
me if I'm wrong, that uh imposing toxic positivity
on other people also sort of uh takes room
from them to express um negative feelings and negative
emotions, right? They, they, they might want to just
naturally express, but because other people. Around them are
just saying, oh no, you're going to get through
this, you're going to survive this and that. I
mean, uh uh maybe the person is just wanting,
oh my God, just let me express sadness or
grief or whatever kind of negative things that are
going through my mind, just let me say goodbye
to people around me, but they're, they're just not
giving them. Yep.
Some people in that thing just want to vent,
you know, they want to be able to say
that they are scared because they're dying. Of course
they are. Um, YOU know, they, they want to
be able to say they're angry at this situation
or they want to be able to, you know,
say final goodbyes to other family members. And then
you always have one family member that is that
toxic positivity, one that is desperately trying to, Uh,
control the situation for their own comfort level, um,
it's a, it's a horrible thing for the individual
to do because it's very self-serving. Um, IT'S not
serving anyone else, definitely not serving the dying person,
and they just want to vent, and they have,
they have that right to vent. If there's any
time to be selfish, it's when you're, you know,
you're actively dying. So, um, yeah, it's, it's a
hard thing to watch and it's a, but it's
even harder to try and get people to turn
that off, um, yeah.
So, uh, what do you think about how society
tends to look at suicide, because I mean, to
a certain extent, of course, I understand why people
have negative views of it, also to discourage people
from going through with it, but on the other
hand, I, I mean, sometimes I get the sense
that people moralize er people who commit suicide too
much as if it's a moral failing on their
part that they didn't want to be here anymore
for whatever reason they might have,
right? Yeah, um. It's, it's a huge problem. I
think people completely refuse to see the nuance and
use critical thinking when it, when it comes to
that, that topic. Um, I've always been a believer,
if you have the right to live, you have
the right to die. Um, AND that means, and
I mean that whether you're healthy or, or not.
Now, a lot of people get up in arms,
but again, there's a lot of nuance in that,
isn't there? Um, AND the The problem is, if
someone does take their own life, um, there are
so many things that happen around that, um, as
well, that's why uh uh assisted dying became a,
became a thing to offset the traumatic past that
suicide would have. But if, for me, if you
decide to take your own life because of that,
and it's been a long-term factor, like if, if
you've, if you've just had a relationship breakup, And
you're in that instant, you're gonna be in grief
because that's your relationship breakup. Well then probably not,
but I think the long-term, people that have been
suffering long-term, um, I don't think anyone really has
the right to criticize what they're going through and
what they can and cannot do with their own
body, with their own life. If, if you have
nothing else that you can control, you can control
whether you live or die. Um, AND I don't
think it's right people should even try to take
that away from, from them when they can take
everything else away from someone.
Yeah, when it comes to the right to die,
I think that people who, I mean, for religious
reasons or even non-religious reasons just oppose that and
oppose medical assistance in dying and whatever kind of
way that people might end their. Lives prematurely. Let's,
I mean, sometimes it's not even that prematurely if
we're talking about people with terminal diseases and, and
things like that, but uh I, I mean, I,
I think that they also can might put people
who don't want to be here anymore uh under
a lot. Of stress and feeling like a caged
in a sense because it's like oh I don't
want to be here anymore, but whichever way I
turn, someone is forcing me into going on living,
right? I mean it can be, I imagine that
it can be very. DAMNING and isolating for the
person who's experiencing that.
The big one is people say, well, live for
me, you know, if nothing else, live for me,
why don't you want to live for me, that
is an extremely manipulative way of, it, it, it's
absolutely horrible way of doing it, um, and there's
a, there's a part of psychology as well that
if you, As a clinician or or someone else,
say, OK, what is your, what is your method,
or whatever, what's your plan? And they say I
have this plan, and instead of jumping down their
throat saying that's a horrible thing, or, you know,
you shouldn't do that, why have you thought of
these reasons to live, sometimes just having that plan
in the back of their mind and knowing that
they have an escape if they want, lets them
live longer. There are plenty of people that, that
know that, you know, I have this plan, I
know it would work. And then they keep that
in the back of the thing or they keep
whatever it is in the back of the wardrobe
or something like that, and they go on to
live another 12 years, you know, 20 years or
whatever, knowing that they have that out if they
want it, and I think that's a, That's a
big, big thing that a lot of people um
don't really think about, it's that nuance, it's that
fear, um, and it's the lack of understanding about
how suicide, um, and suicidality works, um, in for
a lot of people.
Yeah, that that reminds me of a conversation I
had last year with Doctor Philip Nitschke. He's actually
from Australia as well, and uh I mean. Yeah,
and, uh, at a certain point, we were talking
about people getting access to medication for, I, I
mean, it's basically a form of assisted suicide, but
it's the person taking the medication home and then
deciding whether or not they, they want to take
it and when they want to take it and
he told me that for For example, he himself
has medication at home, uh, for that, and he's
had it for the past 20 or 30 years,
and he's still here. So I mean, sometimes it's
just people having that escape door in a sense.
I mean, if at any moment I can no
longer bear existing, I know. That I can get
out of here as soon as possible and with
as little suffering as possible.
Yeah, cos most people that are, have suicidal, suicidal
ideation, have it for a long, long time, sometimes
lifelong. Most people that are suicide and don't do
it impulsively, um, I think that's what a lot
of, a lot of people who have never felt
that way, I think, Kind of believe that it's
an impulsive act, uh, it's really not, and that's
why this having something, you know, locked away somewhere
that you can get to down the track, it's
a, it's a big thing, and it's, I know
a lot of people that have, uh, Of all
ages, of all health levels, um, that have exactly
that, um, that have an out, so they know
it's there, and it makes them feel a lot
more secure in themselves and in their life, and
it fills them a lot, it makes them feel
safe, um, and I, so I think a lot
of people who don't understand the nuance of it,
who have never been there, or are extremely biased
because of society or because of religion or or
whatever else, um, They're actually pushing people closer to
doing it then. If what you do if you
actually have a conversation with someone, because back in
the day, for most countries it was, it was
a crime, to commit suicide, um, you know, that's
why it's called committing suicide, like committing murder, um,
And our society sort of shifted and became a,
a health issue. We changed it, we, we decriminalized
it and then became a health issue. And like
so, so, so many, um, uh, issues and topics,
people swung from this extreme to this extreme. They,
and so many people can't. See the nuance and
the middle part of this ground, so we're currently
over here with the extreme of it being a
health issue and, and, and stuff like that, and
we need to sort of come back to seeing
it in the normal, um, in the regular central
part of it. I don't think it'll, it'll happen
like a lot of topics. I, I think it'll
just keep swinging between the two extremes, but, um,
that would be very helpful for a lot of
people.
Yeah, I, I mean people are so averse to
people committing suicide that then they even put people
who committed suicide in the 6th or 7th circle
of hell. I mean people in the in the
circle of hell of people who were violent in
the end, in that case violent. TO themselves, so
I mean it seems that some people, at least
the religious ones even want to think that if
someone commits suicide, they will be punished in the
afterlife because, because that's just not something that you
can do with your own life.
Yeah, we'll try and keep people alive through fear,
um, and I mean that shows an extreme lack
of critical thinking, extreme lack of understanding of psychology,
um, as it is, that just doesn't work, um.
Yeah. Uh, BY the way, when it comes to
medically, medical assistance in dying, I think that one
of the, of course, uh, the entirety of the
topic is very controversial usually, but, uh, what is
your take on extending it to people who suffer
from psychiatric conditions?
Yeah, uh, it's a complex, uh, it's a very
complex thing to do. Do I think that they
should? Yes. Do I think doing so is an
extreme risk on your system? Yes. We've seen with
Canada recently, it's gotten, uh, things have not gone
well. Um, THEIR system was so young for their
first, for the terminal illness part, and then the
court system said, no, you have to add on
the second tier. Um, AND they weren't ready for
it. It was such a young system, it just,
it, it sort of got out of control and
there was no safeguards. The mechanism, the safeguards weren't
great, the mechanisms weren't great. There was no sort
of review system in place. Um, BUT then you
have other countries, Netherlands and, and such that have
absolutely have it for, for, uh, very, Mental illnesses,
various non-terminal, uh, things, even dementia, that they, that
they have it before, and they have a lot
of safeguards in place, and it is working fine.
You know, it's not like their entire, everyone in
their country who has a mental illness is heading
off to the clinics. You know, I think that's
what a lot of people outside these countries seem
to think will, will happen. People just up and
go. Um, I think it's, I think it's a
good thing, because I don't think, people who have
never dealt with, say, schizophrenia or something like that.
Uh, AGAIN, Don't have a real say on that.
This is the same, you know, there's so many
diagnoses that are so heavily stigmatized, you wouldn't want
to be in the same room with someone, but
now you're telling that person that they can't alleviate
their own suffering because they tell me, trust me,
it's gonna be worse for them to have that
than for you being around them. And, and now
you're saying that they can't, they can't do that.
I think that's appalling, an appalling thought to have.
Dementia is a, a big one that a lot
of people are talking about, a lot of people
over here in Australia are very much want dementia
to be put on the list. Uh, THE big
problem with that is, are they, do they have
capacity at the time, and they, and they don't,
because by the time they got to that point,
they wouldn't have capacity to say yes. In the
Netherlands, um, they did put that in, uh, saying
that that was, uh, an OK thing to do,
but they had to do it while they had
capacity. Um, THEY had to say yes, and there
was a, they tried to extend it a bit.
Um, SAYING that if you, one, at the time
you have dementia, you have that illness. If you
have capacity, you can write it down saying that
at this time where I no longer have it,
I give my rights over to this person, um,
and they will say yes. The amount of people
that actually took that up, say the children of
this person with dementia, the amount of people that
took that up was very, very small. Because the
idea of saying, hey, I'm gonna take mm to
the clinic on Tuesday to effectively, you know, have
her put down, it's sort of like, you know,
that can't sit well in people's minds, so there
wasn't an uptick, like, so many detractors thought there
were. Um, I think, yeah, I think a lot
of European countries are doing very well with it
and provide great templates for what can be done,
but then we have, like, yeah, Canada at the
moment is a great template of how it should
not be done.
Yeah, you know, I think that sometimes people who
oppose euthanasia in general also tend to resort to
underhanded tactics like for example, slippery slope arguments. They,
they abuse those kinds of arguments and also sometimes
trying to associate people who are in favor of.
Medical assistance in dying with, for example, Nazis and
saying, oh, you see that, but, but, but they
fail to make the distinction between involuntary euthanasia and
voluntary euthanasia, right? And then it's like, oh, if
you're in favor of euthanasia, then yeah, I put
this stigma on. You that you're a Nazi or
you're Nazi related or something like that, and for
me it's just silly because it's like someone saying,
oh, you should be careful about vegetarianism because Hitler
was a vegetarian and I'm, I mean, really, is
that the the the road you want to go
on?
It's the slippery slope argument is a ridiculous. Seeing
at the best of times. I mean, you can
say, oh, I shouldn't drive a car because, you
know, you might end up in a car crash.
Ooh, slippery slope, oh, you know, you might, it,
everything's slippery slope until, you know, they actually need
it. And there's a lot of disability activist groups
that are saying, oh no, they'll try and kill
us all off. And again, the Nazis, I mean
the Nazis did plenty, plenty of bad things obviously,
but I mean, in this particular instance, it, they
really screwed over a lot of countries, because that
stigma is still there, um, and quite frankly, I
don't think the people that go out and picket
and say, you know, I'm disabled, you know, they,
they want to get rid of me, if you
are actually out there able to picket, we're not
talking about you, um. Oddly enough, but yeah, it's
a, it's a slippery slope. I mean the UK
has been, uh, debating this for 90 years before
the Nazis, uh, came about, and they had to
change up their whole, uh, the wording because euthanasia
as a word, suddenly wasn't a neutral anymore, so
they had to, they had to change that up,
and of course there's, there's, but there's also different
ways that, um, These programs around the world have
it over here in Australia, the majority is that
you take the medication home with you, and you
take it yourself, whereas in other countries it's a
doctor will inject you, in other countries, so it
makes people very fearful, because they don't know the
process. A lot of people haven't looked into the
process. There's a lot of steps you've gotta go
through, a lot of hurdles you've gotta jump, um,
to, to be on one of these programs.
Mhm. So why is it that er funerals and
other kinds of death related rituals, er, why are
they so important to people in general? I mean,
beyond the fact that or beyond the simple act.
Of burying someone to not, to avoid spreading disease,
for example, what is it that, what are the
social and psychological aspects that surround those kinds of
rituals that make it so important for people to
experience them?
Yeah, so, uh, funeral rituals are mourning rituals and
mourning, Is sort of the activities that we go
through to help process our grief, they give you,
they give you a task to complete while your
brain is elsewhere and unable to really think through
because you're in grief, and then bereavement is the
time that grief and mourning activities happen. So a
funeral gives you that, well, it was meant to
be a place where you could come and grieve
and be supported. By people, um, and you were
supposed to be able to cry out in public,
and you were supposed to be able to, to
feel things and feel supported by the community, and
unfortunately, for, for a lot of countries who have
lost a lot of their death literacy, have high
levels of death anxiety, that's not happening anymore. We've
moved to this celebration of life, which again is
more of a, I put that more in the
toxic positivity box as well, of, It's not a
place to grieve anymore, people are expected to grieve
at home and you come to this celebration of
life which they're calling a funeral and there's not
really any support there anymore because grief is the
process of, Uh, getting used to a new normal,
um, you're gonna go through feelings, and, and that's
not really happening anymore, but that's what the funeral
process originally was, was for and the purpose. Um,
OBVIOUSLY there were religion, religious parts in there as
well for some people, um, and that helped calm
their minds as well, but, um, for us now,
even if you are atheist, that having a funeral,
uh, is still a meaningful, uh, thing to do
for your own grief.
Yeah. So, uh, please correct me if I'm wrong,
but I, I think that I read in your,
uh, website, the website for tabuse education that you
were a psychosexual therapist for a while. So, uh,
do you find any connections between the sexual aspects
of human life and death? And I think that
there are perhaps two avenues that we can go,
uh, that we Can go into when it comes
to this question. I mean one of them is
if uh psychologically there's any connections between uh the
our sexuality and death and the other one is
in terms of taboo topics whether taboo topics related
to sexuality, uh, in, in some way share traits
with taboo topics related to death.
Yeah, um, well, if we look at one way,
um, you are at your most honest and your
most vulnerable when you are dying or you're in
the middle of a sexual activity. um, SO you
are your most honest self. So as far as
a clinician, if you're looking at either of those,
you are getting the most honest person out of
them of who they really, really are. Um, SO
for me, that's where the, the interest is. You
break down a lot of, a lot of walls
real quickly when, when you're talking about what their
sexual attraction is, or, or their, or dying in
general. So that's, that's a really interesting one, but
the more, probably more interesting one is that, um,
yeah, because I, I was a psychosexual therapist, but
I then specialized in kink fetish and paraphilia, um,
which, You wouldn't think death and sex really, uh,
come together all that much, they do, uh, necrophilia
being the most obvious one that people know about,
obviously the attraction to the dead body. So that's,
that's one, but then there's also uh various uh
fetishes that may go on to be paraphilias, uh,
depending on if they act on it or not,
whereas, um, uh, of being dead, of being murdered,
um, murdering someone else, uh, that's not tend, tend
to be the same one, but, um, yeah, there's
a, there's a, there's a range of, of, of
sexual, death for a lot of people can be
quite sexually attractive in, in, Various ways, um, again,
that romanticization that a lot of people have about
death is, is part of that, um, but also,
what happens during puberty and your sexual development as
well impacts, uh, these things, but it can be
very, very interesting and we try on our, on
our channel to add that in as often as
possible because people find it fascinating, so.
Yeah, no, it's, it's really fascinating. So, uh, one
last uh topic I would like to ask you
about, um, is that anxiety something that at least
in certain cases, uh, could or should be treated
in the context of psychotherapy?
Yeah, absolutely. If it is, it's like anything else,
if it is impacting your functioning in any way,
um, and there's 5 different ways, whether it be
professional, your financial, your, all the different ways, if
it is impacting your life, then you need to
chat with someone professionally about it. You need to
sort that issue out. Um, IF that anxiety is
so, Mass that is taking over your life, or
you don't know why you're making the decisions you
are, why you feel anxious, because a lot of
people don't know it is anxiety about death and
dying themselves. They feel anxious, um, then absolutely, you
reach out to someone, reach out to someone like
me, we do educational consults rather than therapeutic ones
now, but just to understand that, um, sort of
things. But you can also help yourself out as
well. There are plenty of ways. Um, TO, to
help yourself cope with it as well, but I
would strongly recommend, um, seeing a professional for
healthcare. Um, AND what do you think, or, or
do you think that there are ways that we
could try to, uh, combat death anxiety that stems
from the fact that people in modern industrialized societies
are much less exposed to people dying and to
death. Cor corpses and all of that, I mean,
do you think that there are ways we could,
uh, sort of circumvent that in any way? I
mean, I don't know. Should people just have, uh,
excursions to auspices or what or see autopsies, or,
I mean, what,
what can we
do
about that? Look, um, yeah, you. People always say,
I, I always say, you know, exposure, and people
automatically mean, oh, I'll go turn up to an
autopsy or something. I'm like, no, that's not the
way it works, the pathologist is not gonna be
happy to see you, I guarantee that. Um, IT'S
going to something like a death cafe, it's talking,
it's going out and talking to things. It's going
and taking walks around cemeteries on a regular basis,
and just engaging with that. There are plenty of
museums out there around the world, I mean I've,
We've we've got a few videos on the massive
list that I'm trying to tick off as I
go around the world, um, of that are medical
based or history based or something that that have
to do with death, and go and interact and
think about it. It's, it's bringing it back to
normality, it's bringing it back to this is real,
this exists, Um, and the more you think about
it and think it through rather than imagining stuff
to fill that void, um, the easier it's gonna
get. So we're not gonna say, I'm not gonna
say go on the internet and look up dead
bodies or something like that, that's not a way
to go, that's a whole different issue. Maybe once
or twice, fine, you know, everyone should see what
a real body looks like, not what's not on
the medical show. Um, BUT yeah, things like walking
through a cemetery would be the, the best thing
that you could do, or going to a museum
and seeing death there would probably be the easiest
way that you can start doing that.
Uh, GREAT, so, uh, I will be sending you
a link to add you as a collaborator on
this video, and apart from your YouTube channel and
your website, which I'm going also to link in
the description, where else can people find you on
the internet? Yeah,
we're on Facebook and Instagram as well, but you
can find all that through our, our website or
through our YouTube channel.
Oh, by the way, would you like to tell
people about your book project in case they're interested
in potentially supporting it?
We are, we're raising money currently to write a
narrative nonfiction book about how death anxiety impacts your
day to day life through the entire lifespan. We're
looking at having Australian and British, specifically, uh, famous
individuals, uh, tell their stories about death anxiety and
death acceptance throughout their lifespan. So we're raising money
cos that's gonna raise a lot of travel, uh,
a lot of editing as well, and I will
get you to put in the, the link to
our fundraiser, uh, on there, otherwise you can find
it on our website, or, uh, in our YouTube
link as well. Anything is much appreciated, even a
few bucks.
Oh, by the way, uh, uh, just before we
started our interview, I went there and donated $25
so I encourage everyone, I encourage everyone to go
there and do the same because I think it
will be a, a fascinating book and uh I
hope to have you back on the show when
it's published.
Oh, that would be great. I can tell you
all the behind the scenes secrets.
OK, so thank you so much for coming on
the show.
Thank you, Ricardo. Thanks for having me.
Hi guys, thank you for watching this interview until
the end. If you liked it, please share it,
leave a like and hit the subscription button. The
show is brought to you by Enlights, Learning and
Development done differently. Check their website at lights.com and
also please consider supporting the show on Patreon or
PayPal. I would also like to give a huge
thank you to my main patrons and PayPal supporters,
Perergo Larsson, Jerry Mulleran, Frederick Sundo, Bernard Seaz Olaf,
Alex, Adam Cassel, Matthew Whittingberrd, Arnaud Wolf, Tim Hollis,
Eric Elena, John Connors, Philip Forrest Connolly. Then Dmitri
Robert Windegerru Inai Zu Mark Nevs, Colin Holbrookfield, Governor,
Michel Stormir, Samuel Andre, Francis Forti Agnun, Svergoo, and
Hal Herzognon, Michel Jonathan Labrarith, John Yardston, and Samuel
Cerri, Hines, Mark Smith, John Ware, Tom Hammel, Sardusran,
David Sloane Wilson, Yasilla Dezara Romain Roach, Diego Londono
Correa. Yannik Puntervan Ruzmani, Charlotte Blis Nicole Barbaro, Adam
Hunt, Pavlostazevski, Alec Baka Madison, Gary G. Alman, Semov,
Zal Adrian Yei Poltontin, John Barboza, Julian Price, Edward
Hall, Edin Bronner, Douglas Fry, Franco Bartolotti, Gabriel P
Scortez or Suliliski, Scott Zachary Fish, Tim Duffyani Smith,
and Wisman. Daniel Friedman, William Buckner, Paul Georg Jarno,
Luke Lovai, Georgios Theophannus, Chris Williamson, Peter Wolozin, David
Williams, Di Acosta, Anton Ericsson, Charles Murray, Alex Shaw,
Marie Martinez, Coralli Chevalier, Bangalore atheists, Larry D. Lee
Junior. Old Eringbon. Esterri, Michael Bailey, then Spurber, Robert
Grassy, Zigoren, Jeff McMahon, Jake Zul, Barnabas Raddix, Mark
Kempel, Thomas Dovner, Luke Neeson, Chris Story, Kimberly Johnson,
Benjamin Galbert, Jessica Nowicki, Linda Brendan, Nicholas Carlson, Ismael
Bensleyman. George Ekoriati, Valentine Steinmann, Per Crawley, Kate Van
Goler, Alexander Obert, Liam Dunaway, BR, Massoud Ali Mohammadi,
Perpendicular, Jannes Hetner, Ursula Guinov, Gregory Hastings, David Pinsov,
Sean Nelson, Mike Levin, and Jos Necht. A special
thanks to my producers Iar Webb, Jim Frank Lucas
Stink, Tom Vanneden, Bernardine Curtis Dixon, Benedict Mueller, Thomas
Trumbull, Catherine and Patrick Tobin, John Carlo Montenegro, Al
Nick Cortiz, and Nick Golden, and to my executive
producers, Matthew Lavender, Sergio Quadrian, Bogdan Kanis, and Rosie.
Thank you for all.